you called yourself the daughter of the
Dragon
sure you want to do it funny oh my honey
again I day I don't know where you came
from
you're welcome any time when we set me
coming she's just trying to survive nuts
again calming working the dojo this year
yeah she looks off the kids these
exercises are about trying to teach you
how to perform in the real world she
represents honor discipline self
discipline she has this edge how about
you add another fighter when I win you
double my payday you are one crazy chick
you know that Colleen isn't a lot of
financial trouble she's in such dire
straits she ends up going to a Fight
Club you ready for the party girl or end
up liking it
[Applause]
that is never thin women is strong and
his face is Colin who won't challenge
master he has to win her over I'm asking
you nicely to leave a fast initial
reaction is you're crazy then when she
sees how good of a fighter is she starts
to realize that's something else about
him
are you dangerous very dangerous she's
curious
he's so intriguing and he's so unlike
anyone she's ever met if you know kill
you that's not going to happen so she
kind of takes a gamble that we can do a
lot of good together
you are the only person who can help me
it's a very dramatic relationship
mysteries such a big part of our show
and there's an element of was it fate
was it meant to be I think she knows
it's Danny's non-graded perhaps but it's
intoxicating
I'm going with you or not anything
Colleen with amazing people will not
work great feminine figure shoes iron
fist is in a league of its own
it's the show that keeps you on your
toes
you
[Applause]
we're gonna stay bring it in
[Applause]
look you guys know all the rules huh
tap out I'll knock out your hallway out
of this cage otherwise whatever work you
sure you want to do
[Applause]
[Applause]
little girl let's go
[Applause]
you